[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
election day is here
if you haven't voted already
if you don't have your plan together get
it together go vote
[Music]
it is most important that every single
person in this country who can and and
is registered to vote should vote today
and have their opinion heard we need to
know exactly what this poll says this is
the most important poll that we are
going to have
for a long time at least two years here
it is super important that you have your
voice heard I don't care who you're
voting for
you need to go vote and we need this
turnout to be huge because I'm very
confident very confident that if this
turnout is huge it will be in favor of
democracy because that's what voting is
that that's that's like the the
foundation
of democracy they want to say oh it's
not a democracy it's a constitutional
republic Charlie Kirk wants to say
democracy is bad then why are you people
voting
if democracy is so bad why are you so
concerned
about voting if democracy is so bad you
would abandon voting for that matter
you wouldn't vote yourself if you don't
believe in democracy
you wouldn't I've been watching and we
have been watching on this show for a
long time
right-wing talkers
traitors to this country people who have
participated and helped the January 6th
Insurrection the overthrowing of our
democracy
promoting the big lie supporting Q Anon
conspiracy theories these folks are
we've never showed them talking about
getting the turnout
they don't talk about it they do not
talk about turning out the vote they
only talk about questioning democracy
questioning the vote
challenging the vote challenging the
results
if it's stolen if it's not
because they do not believe in democracy
they don't that is why they're so upset
that is why they are so [ __ ] pissed
off
that is why they hate the constitution
in the first place
the Constitution was not designed
for their crypto fascist
authoritarianism
it was not designed for that
and that's what really [ __ ] pisses
them off and by them I mean Maga
the America First Nazis
it pisses them off
and I'm here to tell you that they're
scared of it they're terrified of your
voice
because your voice tears apart all their
[ __ ]
all their nonsense all their white
supremacy and their vile gross world
view of what this country is what it
should be
they do not believe in the Constitution
they do not believe in Freedom
they only believe in their freedom to
oppress the rights of other people that
is the freedom they believe in
and that is why it is so important for
you to use your Liberty and your right
today to go vote to show them how you
feel about their world view
this is not this is not about abortion
this is not about this is not about the
economy or gas prices this is not about
inflation
this is about the survival of the idea
that if you afford everyone Rights and
Freedoms
that it will deliver them Liberty
Equity equality it is a hard [ __ ]
thing to do
democracy is difficult it's a
[ __ ] to get a shitload of people
to agree and compromise on a set of
principles it's a [ __ ]
but that's what democracies do and
that's what pisses them off
they don't want to settle on principles
they want to be able to tell you what
religion you have what medical
procedures you can have and what choices
you can make with your doctor they want
to tell you what [ __ ] books your
children can read what schools they can
go to
what churches you can have in your town
who can sit on your community boards
and in your public offices they want to
tell you what they want to do that is
their freedom that's not Freedom folks
that's oppression that's fascism
and today is the day if you have not
already and I know a lot of people in
the chat have said you voted
and that is absolutely crucial that you
vote
and you encourage others to vote
a friend a family member we're down to
the wire here every single last vote
will count towards the final tally
of where this country stands
it is super important it doesn't matter
about who wins
it really doesn't now the problem that
the America first fascist the American
first Nazis Maga has
is that they don't believe in democracy
anymore they don't believe in voting
that's the problem that they have with
turnout
that's why turnout is going to favor the
pro-democracy party the Democrats
that's why
it's only in the nature of democracy
if the Republican party still was
Tethered to reality and not often some
[ __ ] Q Anon ocean with con floating
around with conspiracy theories
and still had some tie to being
pro-democracy
the turnout would benefit them but it
won't because they aren't
so everyone's talking about closing
arguments and how to make the closing
argument
the closing argument is this
do you want them to have the freedom to
oppress you
is that what you want
that's what they want they're yelling it
and screaming it out loud they're
telling you
we've been listening to them on this
show for well over a year
I've been pounding the airwaves every
single day for two full hours and I will
not stop even after this election and I
want to get to that too
but they've been telling you their goal
is to oppress your rights because they
think they know better based on their
Supremacy
trust me I know this all too well I've
watched it growing up I grew up in it
institutionalized into white supremacy
not knowing it having no [ __ ] clue
that that's what was going on
how the people the people institution
making it an institution for people to
grow up in they didn't even know and
some of these folks still don't know
that's what's happening
it's fascism folks it's white supremacy
it's white nationalism
and they've disguised it as a religion
hell not even disguised it anymore Q
Anon is their religion
and it's dangerous
not just not just to our government not
just to our way of life our way of life
like our freedoms
equality and Equity
but also our actual lives and your
children's lives
if you just take a step step back in
history and look at when fascism rares
its ugly head
all the same checklist is here
the good news is is we have each other
we have our democracy we have our
constitution we have our fabric of our
nation
and you better use that fabric now while
we still have it
it is super important to vote
stand in line until until midnight if
you have to
pull a provisional ballot in your state
if you have to there's a number right
now 866 hour vote if you have any
trouble at the poll and it doesn't
matter who you're voting for it doesn't
matter
866 hour vote
if you're having trouble casting your
ballot they will help you
it is so important today that you use
your Civic power
of your one ballot but more than
anything the power of your voice your
freedom of speech
today is the day now is the time we are
here we're finally here to show these
fascists to show these America First
Nazis
exactly
exactly how we feel about them
and they're listening they're here
listening to me right now and the reason
why they're listening to me right now is
because they're terrified of my voice
and it ain't because I say something
special
it's because you listen
it's because you listen because let me
tell you something about the Republican
Party
for decades and decades and decades
they've used rhetoric they've used the
narrative and Democrats have always
placated the media has always placated
to that narrative and we will [ __ ]
not hear it just won't happen here on my
show not while I'm here it will not
happen
we will not placate to their stupid
[ __ ] lies to their stupid [ __ ]
narrative
twisting of the American dream I don't
think so
not gonna happen and that's why they're
terrified of you
because I believe this turnout that we
have seen so far
in the absentee the mainland ballot and
the early vote and the lines that are
forming today that are record-setting
is because you
you are sick and tired of their [ __ ]
lies you are sick and tired of hearing
their complete utter [ __ ] nonsense
and you're sick and tired of being told
what you can and what you cannot do
why they thought that they could hitch
their wagon to telling people what to do
in this country I have no idea
but they have done it and that's where
they're at
so use the power of your voice
use the Hat the Civic Hammer that you
have
with your ballot
now is the time right now that's the
closing argument
there's no other argument that needs to
be had
other than if you want to keep voting
you must vote
you're powerful
you may just be one vote in one voice
but you're powerful
in a democracy when we band together and
we say no to Fascism it doesn't matter
what we disagree on
it doesn't matter if we're five dollars
here or five dollars here off from the
minimum wage it doesn't matter if you're
all in on union labor or not on on the
union labor it doesn't matter our
differences on Health Care our education
it doesn't matter
we don't get to argue those things
without a democracy
we don't get to compromise on those
issues we don't get to debate line items
and bills without our democracy
who gives a [ __ ] if you're a socialist
if you're a registered Democrat if
you're a liberal
if you're an independent or a moderate
or a never Trumper I don't give a [ __ ]
at this point
if your goal is to make sure that we can
argue these things in the future
now is the time to vote vote vote vote
and vote pro-democracy
if you want to argue those things
because they are telling you they're not
going to argue those things
they're not going to argue these things
Doug mastriano the [ __ ] Pennsylvania
Hitler
this guy's running for governor says
that he's going to make sure that
Schools elementary schools can't have
pronoun flash cards
think about this for a [ __ ] second
they literally have gone so far off the
[ __ ] deep end that they're gonna make
sure elementary schools don't teach
children pronouns I'm not talking about
what their pronouns are and all this
[ __ ] they are terrified of [ __ ] words
and they are they want to ban rather
elementary schools can teach children
grammar
in Florida they're banning math and Book
Fairs
they want they they're telling women you
can't make medical decisions We're Men
and we're local politicians we get to
make your medical decisions
you want your democracy
do what democracies do best
vote them the [ __ ] out
who cares if you don't agree with
fetterman who gives a rats [ __ ] ass
if you don't like Tim Ryan I don't give
a [ __ ] how you feel about Val demmings
Charlie Chris or Beto O'Rourke don't
give a [ __ ] what you think about Katie
Hobbs or Mark Kelly
it's not time to pick apart their
[ __ ] beliefs
now is the time to save our democracy
from the people who will take your
[ __ ] beliefs away from you
they will force you
this is what they do
this is what they're telling you out
loud that they are going to do
so are you going to allow them
are you going to allow them to tell to
you your neighbors your family your
children your grandchildren
your co-workers your fellow parishioners
the people at the PTA are you gonna
you're gonna let them tell you and and
your community what to do
are you gonna let them tell you who the
[ __ ] you who the [ __ ] you can believe in
and not who the [ __ ] you can vote for
and who you cannot
you're gonna let them tell you who you
can [ __ ] love and who you can't
you're are you gonna let them tell your
friends and your family who they can be
how they can [ __ ] dress
this is what they're saying folks out
loud listen to them but more than
anything
use the power of your mind
and the power of your ballot
to show them who you are and Who We Are
because more than we need to send a
message to each other in the world we
have to send a message to them
enough of the [ __ ] you you better
[ __ ] change your [ __ ] or crawl back
underneath your [ __ ] rock
because this democracy this nation
we the people are not going to tolerate
your intolerance it will not happen
you are the greatest audience in the
world and you're growing by Leaps and
Bounds
and I appreciate having you here every
single day
and we will not stop after today today
is not the last day to fight for our
democracy it is not
today may just be the beginning
it may just be the beginning to fight
for our democracy because there's one
thing for sure that these uh these
[ __ ] fascists have keep saying out
loud is that no matter what if they lose
they're going they're going to lie
they're going to lie lie lie lie lie
like they've never lied before
and they just may they just may try to
commit violence
so I'm not gonna stop because today is
not the last day for democracy
it may just be the first
because they're gonna keep going
they're not going away
fascism
is not a cute idea
it is a movement
and and that is what we are fighting
because we have we have to save our
democracy by stopping their movement
because today the ballots will be cast
tonight and tomorrow and and early into
the morning tomorrow they will be
counted
we will have results tonight and
tomorrow
we will know we will know more about how
this country really stands
by Wednesday afternoon
but it will not stop there
because as soon as this election that
you're voting in today
is done counted and certified
we got another one that's the most
important election of our lifetime
so we cannot stop fighting today is only
the beginning
of our fight of our resistance
against their oppression against their
white supremacy against their fascism
this is just the beginning folks
and we will have to keep sending
messages every single day
because they will not they will not
relent they are hell-bent
on telling you who you can be and who
you cannot be who you can love and who
you cannot love what medical procedures
you can have and what medical procedures
you cannot have what books your children
can read and what books they can't read
what clothes you wear even they're
saying how you dress
who you can marry they want to marry in
Tennessee they want to marry children
in Florida they're banning Book Fairs
and Pennsylvania masciana wants to wants
to ban pronoun flash cards and grammar
really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] folks Kerry
Kerry Lake
in Arizona wants to overturn the last
election
when we're voting in this election
bone-headed [ __ ]
but they are not going to stop and
neither should you
and that's why I will keep yelling and
screaming into this microphone for two
full hours every single weekday you can
bet your [ __ ] ass on it
from noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and my Facebook page today
is Tuesday it's election day
but Tuesday is a special day here at the
Tony Michaels podcast you know
that we have Texas Paul on every Tuesday
and he is here today on Election Day and
I bet I almost [ __ ] because I know
Paul really well I almost bet
that he is as fired up about democracy
and about winning as much as I am today
and I almost bet that he is very
confident
super confident and super optimistic
about our democracy and our chances
today for the pro-democracy arm of this
country
to go vote and to win this thing I know
he's super confident and we're going to
hear from Texas Paul today at the bottom
of the hour
but it's also Taco Tuesday and I have
I have a special thing that I won I
posted a few days ago I found it um on
Twitter
and it is a slim jim taco and there was
a lot of talk about it so I want to make
sure that we get because not everything
I want to make something light-hearted
today we can't be all serious all the
time we have to lean into our democracy
and engage but
we also have to talk food with Texas
fall it has become a theme when he's on
the show we talked about spam before and
several other things so I I made sure
that um Texas Paul and Gabe Sanchez knew
that we were going to talk about this
special cheese whiz slim jim tacos so I
don't want you to let me forget because
I know we're going to get fired up about
voting I know we're going to get fired
up about the optimism of our democracy
so I don't want the audience in the chat
to forget that we have to have to have
to have a conversation
about why it is so important that we try
this slim jim cheese whiz taco
now that we're at Taco Tuesday so
everyone stick around we're gonna be
right back right after these messages
Texas Paul is going to join us Gabe
Sanchez is going to join us we're going
to talk about voting because it's
[ __ ] election day so vote vote vote
if you have not already go get in line
hell you can watch this thing on your
cell phone through your airpods while
you're standing in line make sure make
sure your vote counts and call 866 hour
vote if you have any trouble at the
polls again that number is 866 hour vote
if you have any trouble at the polls at
all
and thank you for joining us you're the
best audience in the world we run on
your support if you want to support us
here at the Tony Michaels podcast go to
tonymichaels.live you can leave a tip
there and you one time tip or a monthly
tip we appreciate any of the proceeds
that you give to keep us going also
don't forget to visit
store.thetonymichaels.com that's
store.dtonymichaels.com everyone's been
loving these the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people it's not
Liberties sweatshirts hoodies and zip up
hoodies grab them
it's cold out there
it's cold out there everyone stick
around and we will be right back with
Texas Paul right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them Buckle [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we're hanging through the break we got
Texas ball with us and we do every
Tuesday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific two
full hours on YouTube Twitter and twitch
simulcasting from the minus touch
Facebook page and my Facebook page so
don't forget if you're on Facebook right
now right now if you're on Facebook
right now go over and follow at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook you don't want to
miss some of those means that I pop over
there Texas Paul welcome to the show as
always on Tuesday how are you my friend
Tony you know I love you right I mean
you're like a brother from another
mother okay
um but [ __ ] you [ __ ] your taco [ __ ] the
guy that went and bought the Slim Jims
[ __ ] the guy that made the taco [ __ ] the
guy that took the picture [ __ ] the guy
that sent it to you
listen [ __ ] the [ __ ] that works
at the cheese whiz Factory that [ __ ] is
nasty man I'm wrong with you I have not
tried this yet I was hoping you were
Gabe Sanchez would give it a whirl
before he talked about it but obviously
you guys did not feel that this was a um
a viable uh food option in the comments
so but we're we're gonna go over this
when we get um when we get our burrito
connoisseur here on um that's his it's
self-proclaimed Gabe Sanchez he knows a
lot he he you know he lives in L.A so he
goes to like a lot of taco trucks all
the time and the guy is constantly
making all tacos you know his dad owns a
Mexican restaurant so he grew up in that
world and I'm always I've always been
fascinated to talk to him because I love
tacos I love tacos
but I never really knew what it was and
I'm I'm curious to know because Gabe
Sanchez says if you just put whatever
you want in a in a certain type of
tortilla it might just be a taco so I
wanted to make sure rather The Slim Jims
and the cheese whiz would classify I
don't know maybe you could probably open
up a food truck just selling slim jim
cheese whiz tacos I think you could do
it oh yeah absolutely in this country oh
yeah absolutely good yeah no absolutely
there are Parts in this country that you
could serve that as the main which it is
grossing nobody gonna eat it that [ __ ]
is gross man
well maybe maybe maybe one of these days
I'll just do it live on air it is
election day Texas Paul
um and I know you're just as fired up
about election day and voting as I am
and I think you're very optimistic about
our chances here you know we're not
naysayers we're not you know Debbie
downers I never really believe the
[ __ ] polls in the first place I
thought it was always [ __ ] but I
talked yesterday about gen Z
and their early turnout here and what
they're doing isn't it amazing I mean I
really I I feel more optimistic about
our democracy now than I did in 2020
watching gen Z doing what they're doing
the organizing the early voting I mean
these activists
um are clearly clearly having a a large
effect on that generation would you
agree with that
yeah and it's [ __ ] fantastic man it
really is because
finally starting to seep in with that
generation that the reason policies are
so [ __ ] up in this country is because
nothing but [ __ ] blue hairs vote
if you want young forward-looking
policies in this country
you young people have to vote you've got
to make those politicians want to keep
you happy right well it's quite simple
the calculus is that simple and the
other thing too that I'm excited about
is is
um more younger folks are running for
office but more than anything it's not
really about the office that really gets
me excited is some of these activists
that are out there working so hard to
activate that vote because you're right
it really I mean at the end of the day
it doesn't matter who the politician is
it does but in this point in our history
when we're fighting for democracy more
than we're fighting for any policy it
really matters who the constituency is
that's why these [ __ ] idiots like Ron
DeSantis and mastiano and Kerry Lake and
JD Vance and Dr Oz seem so [ __ ] loopy
and crazy is because the Tale in in our
country the tale really does Wag the Dog
right it really does and Democrats have
never really been able to take advantage
of that really sense bill Bill Clinton I
don't believe that even Barack Obama won
on the tail wagging the dog it was more
actual hope and change like there was a
movement for that but in in the 90s when
Clinton won it was tail wagging the dog
but because Bill Clinton kind of changed
when he lost his midterm right he kind
of changed he went more moderate but
that is how politics work but what
people have never understood until this
gen Z generation and these activists
they have never understood that they
have to be the tail like you gotta
[ __ ] wagon you gotta yell and you
gotta scream and they'll listen because
they need your [ __ ] vote to be a
politician they need your vote to be in
that position to set those policies is
that what you're saying
yeah absolutely but I said it in one
sentence
I have to fill space and I have to give
everyone the chance to hear you know at
least six different ways of how to say
I'm just messing with you but that was
very eloquent that was a very eloquent
descriptor of exactly what we're talking
about young people are starting to
finally figure out that if you want
Forward Thinking policies that are
designed to make this country better or
for decades to come you need to show
your young asses up at the poll because
they will not do it they will you
remember that Mike Lee clip that's been
was circulating just like last week all
them all them gray hairs in there that
were donors were promised hey you can
keep your Social Security but we'll [ __ ]
the next guy
right that's because the next guy wasn't
in the room right
you know and and you want you want them
to to create policies geared for the
future take your young ass to vote we
need you to do it for God's sakes we
need you to do it I mean if they just
keep catering to these Boomer [ __ ]
you know and not all Boomers or [ __ ]
not all boomers are [ __ ] but a good
you know a good half of them you know
take it easy our audience our audiences
that you know they've got they know some
Boomers here they know them though but
they know who I'm talking about they
know the sorry bastards we're talking
about I mean hell you you've been a
local here she's fond of standing on
these old [ __ ] oxygen lines you know
so you know oh sorry I didn't see that
you know well
um she's a badass we have our uh um taco
and burrito connoisseur um joining us so
let's see if he can give us an idea Gabe
Sanchez welcome to the show you're not
that late no you know I had some things
out of you know hey I like your go vote
sign I'm like no yeah well I just you
know pretty pretty simple you know I'm
not telling anyone who to vote for
though I do think that it would be in
your best interest to vote blue but
that's you know well I mean you know if
you want if like I said in the first 30
minutes if you want to keep your vote
you might want to vote for the party
that wants you to have a vote I mean I'm
just saying right yeah yeah that would
probably don't happen to me today what's
that
I was on I was on Twitter this morning
and you know I I'm not a guy that just
you know oh let me say something and
leave and y'all be glad I I blessed you
with my verdictions
I resemble that remark I hang out and I
talk to people and one person was like
hey I've got a serious ethical question
for you
um I normally give people rights to the
polls but I know the people that I've
been given rides to are right Wingers
and I'm not doing it this year I'm not
going to do it I'm not I'm not going to
give them a rights to the boat you know
is that wrong and I said no that's not
wrong that's not wrong and then somebody
else chines in and says yeah tell them
the polling day it will be much uh the
lines will be much smaller tomorrow and
they're handing out Chick-fil-A coupons
I'm like now hold on hold on no we're
not them you cannot pass out
misinformation you can't do that you
know as as much as it pains me to say it
these [ __ ] have the right to vote
just as much as we do and you can't [ __ ]
them over as soon as I finish that I got
a report in from an apartment complex a
couple Towns over
the power company is shutting off power
today as fast as they can
because
they don't want poor broke people voting
and if you've got something you got to
do like get your power back on so your
kids have power tonight because it's
going to get cold here tonight
you're not going to be voting you're
going to be standing in that [ __ ]
line where they got one [ __ ] person
working to turn people's power back on
how cold Texas ball does it get there I
mean
really
I'm just saying I'm just saying it's
Texas old okay it's going to be down in
the 40s it's Texas cold well well
because this there's something there's
something that happened yesterday in
Texas about Texas I mean that is True
Blood Texas yesterday that happened that
a lot of people have been debating on
the internet now everyone knows the
Houston Astros won the World Series
right
um there was there was a right there
well depending on who you are go or [ __ ]
them but here's the thing
um is that they had a parade yesterday
[ __ ]
hey I I I'm a St Louis Cardinals Fan so
you know so well okay and and Gabe
Sanchez the Cubs fan over here shaking
his head what are you oh
[Applause]
hey
almost everything but not [ __ ]
baseball okay so here's the thing they
had a parade yesterday in celebration of
this World Series whatever that is um I
guess it's the championship of a Major
League Baseball am I getting that right
okay so here's the thing they had a
parade yesterday and I'm not really sure
why
um Dan Patrick thought it was a good
idea to be in the parade in Houston but
it was even a worse idea for Senator
Cancun Cruz to be in the [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] break now I tell you there's a
lot of video because there was hundreds
thousands of people on this Parade route
and there was a lot of cameras taking a
lot of video especially of Ted Cruz and
that [ __ ] was getting booed not
just in one spot the entire route like
everybody likes Ted Cruz not a [ __ ]
person was cheering and what's the one
video that I thought was the greatest is
because there was another truck behind
Ted Cruz that was not a politician I
think
um but Ted Cruz's truck goes through the
crowd and they're like
in this person's truck comes like yay
yay Parade route was booing Ted Cruz you
could clear about something too because
I have a Texas Paul reminded me of
something now in in those in that kind
of scene of people booing somebody threw
a beer can at Ted Cruz now a two I think
two two okay now what I want to say is
like I'm not saying that okay Ted Cruz
is a shitty person who you know clearly
doesn't stand up for others especially
his own wife okay now I don't advocate
for somebody chucking a can at someone
like that you know you can Boo and do
other things but like we're not gonna
play into that all right so like I just
want to be clear because I I feel like
I've seen a couple of comments be like
advocating for violence we never even
commented on the violence right but I
just want to say like I don't
I don't Advocate and neither of these
two guys advocate for somebody chucking
a beer can from the side at someone now
I'm not saying like again I'm not saying
Ted Cruz isn't a shitty person because
he is but I don't think that that really
is a deserving kind of action for him so
no it's [ __ ] stupid you can crack
somebody's head open with a beer can it
weighs enough you if you if you chunk it
as hard as somebody like me or somebody
you know just a big old boy gets his
hand on that beer can and whips it you
know hard enough to put a curve on that
sumbitch you can you can crack
somebody's skull with that you can kill
somebody with a beer can that's [ __ ]
stupid but that being said I want to
know why did they both have beer cans I
want to know why did the guy that threw
the beer can why was he in his underwear
I want to know why one of the beer cans
came from inside the truck oh my God
was this like a prostate gay
prostitution thing going bad
I mean is that what was going on here
well I think I think what you're
referring to is a different um a
different conspiracy theory altogether
but I know what you're doing here
because no why did Ted Cruz know his
name why did he say oh come on Chad
why did he know his name
I I I I I
so here's here's the thing because you
can make jokes about it it is a thing
you can joke about because apparently
you can joke about someone's head
getting smashed in with a hammer it's a
thing that you can joke about it's a
thing you can say it's funny but here's
what I'll tell you about the beer can
being thrown especially in a World
Series parade now there are beer cans
thrown a lot in sports uh parades
there's actually where beer cans
throwing thrown at the Astros for them
to catch and to drink in that parade now
I will say because I shared videos of it
so people could see it because I don't
think you have to look away from it but
here's what I'll say about the beer can
being throw it thrown at Ted Cruz versus
the beer can being thrown at the Astros
the first beer can that was thrown at
Ted Cruz it looked like it possibly
could have been thrown for someone to
catch because the guy standing next to
him caught the son of a [ __ ] the second
one was thrown at Ted Cruz's head now
Ted Cruz to think that he was gonna have
a good time right yeah there you go to
think that Ted Cruz Ted Cruz to think
that he was going to have a good time
being in this parade with with thousands
of people from Houston who are sick and
tired of his [ __ ] where he packed his
[ __ ] he packed his [ __ ] and left and and
snowmageddon
he packed his [ __ ] and he went to Cancun
he got caught and to think that that
still does not have a visceral effect it
doesn't matter who the [ __ ] you like
what party you are
nobody likes that [ __ ] for a
reason now the guy apparently went to
court and he apologized he said it was
stupid and I guess he's I don't know
he's like in his 30s or some [ __ ] and
and by the way they weren't beers I I
think they were white claws so let's
just let's not that's not too [ __ ]
out of him
they were white clothes [ __ ] that guy
who drinks why what kind of preppy [ __ ]
bastard drinks
for your old lady
man see on the girl beer [ __ ] I am not
opposed to Hamming uh um a seltzer water
that has alcohol in it so I think they
taste delicious by the way and I bet
Gabe Sanchez who loves him some streamed
water would agree that seltzer water
with alcohol in it seltzer water with
alcohol is good I'm not a big white claw
kind of guy there are some other options
I would recommendations right now both
of you right now I want you to take I
want you to look down I want you to pull
your pants forward and look oh my God
okay is there a penis down there with
this [ __ ] listen listen God damn it
because there's a penis down there don't
ever talk to me about seltzer water
again it's whiskey and beer that's it
I am a hundred percent
here in my manhood that I can sip on a
mixed drink a martini or a seltzer water
with alcohol in it any time of the day
now what I wouldn't do without joking
because I'm a pina colada drinking
[ __ ] you probably would be but
here's the thing what I wouldn't do is
toss a very a very drinkable beer or
seltzer water or anything else and waste
it on someone like [ __ ] Ted Cruz
that's what I know that's what that
judge should have told him [ __ ] your
apology that's alcohol abuse one year
right right so now this guy is going to
be punished for it you know and and you
know you know again they they saw them
ran away it was easy to spot this guy
because he's the only guy tossing beers
quote unquote beers out of the crowd and
at the truck but again
this idea this idea that Ted Cruz
thought it was a good idea to get in the
back of a truck and wave at the
constituents that he [ __ ] abandoned
yeah when I mean
you know is absolutely craziness right
and we saw we saw the visceral reaction
that people had to Ted Cruz at the
Astros game you would think that it's
like okay I'm in a state of even New
Yorkers hate me right you would think
like based on my history and what I've
done or rather lack thereof for the
State of Texas I probably shouldn't put
myself out there in front of a crowd of
people as a Target
for reactions that people have against
you because again you're a terrible
person who has not helped your state I
mean I think in what in the last it was
25 years Republicans have had control of
Texas I think is what I recently was
reading and it was talking about
different policies and laws that were
passed and nothing you know 25 years or
so of actual uh leadership uh in power
and no actual help has been done to
people and even in the last two years
right during the pandemic after the
pandemic Texans have gone through
weather
you know [ __ ] hitting the fan no help
grid shutting down power shutting down
even today I mean these are all voter
suppression tactics obviously
um and there was one thing actually that
that I just want to touch on for a
second that Texas Paul brought up which
is on the electricity side
so I used to campaign for the Obama uh
well campaign in Milwaukee when I lived
there and one of the things that we
found socialist yeah I know uh this is
on the earth this is 2008 so this is you
know or 2007. this is uh early on but
one of the things that we found rampant
before like leading up to the election
was going around and finding fake Flyers
misinformation of somebody putting on a
door and saying your local polling place
is at XYZ and then the the intent of
that is that that person would take a
bus go to that spot they find out it's
not really a polling place or it doesn't
really exist they look around they can't
find they say well [ __ ] I gotta get to
work I've already planned my day to vote
in the morning I got to get to work and
now I'm working till six or seven the
polls are closing I can't actually get
to that spot I need to get home I have
children a family I need to take care of
and at that point boom no vote no vote
is a good vote for Republican because it
means it's not a vote against them and
so we had to go around and actually go
door to door to door to door to talk to
these people to say hey just so you know
this is your polling place ignore the
other flyers are getting or the other
pamphlets you're getting this is the
spot we have you on this address here it
is here's the actual information given
by the city of Milwaukee so you know
that this is real
um you can go there between these times
and this time and it's it is one of
those things where it's like that is why
you also see Republicans they don't want
to make Election Day a national holiday
because they don't want to allow people
the access or the accessibility
to get to a poll without having to deal
with oh [ __ ] I gotta take my kids to
school I got to get to work on time I
gotta do this especially if you don't
actually have a car and you have to rely
on public transportation that's a whole
nother variable and these are all things
that Republicans do and that's you know
obviously one of the oldest tricks in
the book and there are ways to prevent
that in ways to combat that now as we've
you know uh gotten more Democrats in
power to help fight that voter
suppression but even in this election
we've seen crazy things that have
happened right in Pennsylvania Arizona
don't you think because we were talking
about gen Z earlier don't you think
that's why they haven't had the effect
on gen Z because they don't really play
that [ __ ] like they're a generation
that that understands the internet
understands online they understand that
[ __ ] way better than anyone else has
ever has and it's because it's been
their entire life right they've never
known a time where there wasn't the
internet right like a 20 year old today
or 22 year old today or even an 18 year
old today doesn't know anything else but
having the internet so I think I think
those type of tactics they're dying out
if we can get the younger generation to
get engaged with these activists
um Olivia uh Juliana from from Texas
being one of them that has really
engaged the entire movement and I I mean
that's one bad ass [ __ ] right there let
me tell you and let me tell you what let
me tell you what um the reason why
Republicans [ __ ] hate her guts is
because she's not gonna go away and
she's gonna be a force to be reckon with
in activating that generation to stay in
politics and I'll tell you that I think
that's the reason why because
um we're gonna see some surprises in
this election we're going to see some
surprises there's going to be races
where you're gonna be like whoa [ __ ]
even I didn't see that coming and I
think it's because that those tactics
really doesn't work on that generation
because they what what the [ __ ] a door
hanger right like they're like no I
gotta I got a text message right so I
mean I mean I believe that that those
type of tactics aren't going to work on
this generation and
um I I believe that that as we get
further and further into the future it's
gonna it's only gonna be better and
better because these polls suck I mean
they were terrible this last two months
of how they how they pulled this because
I think that's another thing is Gen Z
can't be pulled what do you think that's
Paul
well I think that you're you're hitting
exactly the head on why uh Republicans
have told us that if they win this
election today that they're going to do
away with democracy they're going to
send it to State Legislature state
legislatures that are already elected to
decide who wins elections they're not
going to allow people to vote because
they know The Jig Is up man it's over
it's done these old [ __ ] are done
they know it and they know that people
are paying attention now you get
somebody to vote into one that came out
to vote for the first time in 2018 I
guarantee you they're watching this
election they are voting they're paying
attention to the issues you know once
that's that [ __ ] gets in your
bloodstream you know this politic [ __ ]
is like heroin man once it's in your
bloodstream dude you crave it you want
to know you figure out hey I can affect
[ __ ] around here and all of a sudden
people are like wow yeah let's do this
you know I mean it never ever goes away
once you get somebody voting they will
continue to vote and the Republican
voter base are dying they are dying
those old [ __ ] in in in in The
Villages in Florida and you know I'll be
honest with you there's a couple guys
that were not bad guys and I hate to say
this about them but you know what I know
three [ __ ] that aren't canceling my
votes out
you know why
dead as [ __ ] door Nails it's tough to
vote it's tough to vote when you're
taking a dirt nap isn't it yeah well I
mean that's what happens when you follow
a party that doesn't actually believe in
science doesn't believe in human rights
or health care or the fight the the
well-being of their Community those are
the people that you know I mean
Republicans also realize this after 2020
and lean into 2021 they were like oh
[ __ ] our strategy of covid is a hoax is
is not a great strategy because what
they learned was those people were
actually like oh yeah I don't I don't
need a vaccine I don't need to distance
myself I don't need to wear a mask I can
go into popular I'm going to go to yeah
you're like those people are no longer
an issue because they said kovid's not a
real thing it's a hoax I'm gonna do this
then they get sick and then they die and
they've lost themselves a constituent or
someone who would vote for them and you
know I don't feel an ounce sorry for
them I don't feel an outside for them
because when this started the Trump
Administration you have to you have to
have a long memory you do you can't have
that memory of a goldfish that most
people do when this started they were
[ __ ] cool with it because it looked
like it's going to be them Democrat
cities that get it you know that's all
it's going to be and then they realize
that the [ __ ] they said really screwed
them because we would take the goddamn
vaccine we would wear our masks we would
do [ __ ] that cyan you know scientists
told us to do and all of a sudden you
take a look now and it's about one to
three we're about 25 percent of who died
in covid and those [ __ ] are about 75
percent of who died and they earned
every bit of it they did they earned
everything because of the misinformation
and disinformation and here's what I'll
tell you that they told their own people
that's right well but the lies the lies
I think have have a a significant effect
on suppression as well and we can again
if we're not goldfish we can remember
back in Georgia in the 2020 election
when there was a runoff for both those
Senate seats and Trump himself when
he locked up it's okay he'll be back
yeah he'll be back all right well now
it's the Texas Paul and Gabe show Tony
Frozen
but yeah that's fun with this [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know when he's gonna
come back but I'll at least continue oh
I mean he's gone all right it officially
is the game and Texas Paul show but I
think what Tony was trying to say is uh
is that in in Georgia right even for the
2020 runoff we found that this is
something that it is not going to stop
right the type of acts like you know
even making giving out water to people
who are in line is illegal like some of
these laws that they passed in Georgia I
don't know what happened I don't know
yeah I think I think I think I think the
uh I think someone's trying to get me to
shut up you locked up on me now yeah
there's Cody there he is welcome back
man welcome back I'm here they're trying
to stop we carried you that's good
I didn't know where you were going but I
was I I I uh brought up the fact of how
George even in the runoff election like
right you know continue that's exactly
where I was going with Trump with the
lies right and and and because I think
that that's going to suppress their vote
right like I I cannot believe that that
every single right-wing Trader TV uh
station that you talk about with
coverage for today's election basic
they're saying we're gonna fight the
fraud and it's like why aren't you
saying go vote like literally if you
would just activate your base and they
would go vote you'd have a chance but
they can't say that because they painted
themselves into this corner that voting
is bad democracy is bad you can't trust
machines you can't trust voting don't go
vote we'll just we'll just overturn it
for you and literally their entire base
has started to believe that that
nonsense of self-suppression and and
really if you think about it in our
history and and modern modern times the
Democratic party with self-suppression
has flipped with the Republican party
because Democrats always used to do this
stuff right they used to say stuff like
oh they're going to steal your vote
anyways it'll never count they try to
stop you from voting there's nothing you
can do to vote you shouldn't even
register the vote because they're trying
to prevent you from voting so I'm not
even going to vote the Democratic party
and the Democratic base would do that
[ __ ] a lot even with young folks but
it's completely flipped on its head and
Trump did that and Trump sowed this this
absolutely insane Q Anon type religion
into a small majority of the country the
loudest of the [ __ ] right and
everyone thinks that it's some kind of
big majority that's going to win them
elections and it's not
um and I think that that is the gift
that keeps on giving with Trump
um and I that's why I really want him to
announce the run but right but it's also
the financial Siobhan's question pardon
me over there in the chat Siobhan's
question uh yeah I think Beto's going to
win today I think it's going to be a
shocker about how much he wins too
sorry commenter was asking me questions
uh nice well so so so
um what what do you think the margin is
in Texas for Beto I mean your confidence
is going to win so I mean four to five
points I think people are going to be
shocked at it's going to be a solid four
to five points I do I don't think it's
gonna be a squeaker I don't think it's
gonna be a one-point race I think I've
seen so many people that are Republicans
that that have been lifelong Republicans
because you know 25 years of this
culture War they they've just signed
they've been there for it you know uh
but when you look around and you see
your neighbors are dying
uh either from the cold or covid or you
know whatever or and all the Republicans
have are ridiculous we happen to
understand a lot of us happen to
understand the oil and gas industry here
so I mean he
we happen to know a little bit about
that
um because so many people's paychecks
come from it
um
and and even though you see some dumb
[ __ ] some some Roughnecks are just
brain damage but uh for the most part
people understand
Joe Biden's been fantastic for the oil
and gas industry around here I mean he
they're not hating on on Democrats like
Republicans want them to they're just
not I think you're going to be surprised
at the demographics too I mean I really
do isn't it funny how when corporations
make a lot of money like in the oil and
gas industry and they kind of gouge
Americans and it's not actual inflation
and how it helps the oil and gas
industry and it kind of I don't know
what's that word trickles down
um so I mean I mean that's that's the
funny part about all this but
um you know we were talking this morning
Texas ball on Twitter there was a sign
and I think I think Caitlin may have
posted this thing
um originally but I I retweeted this
sign I think this I think someone was
saying it was in Connecticut
um this is a real thing like this is a
sign it says democracy is overrated vote
Republican holy [ __ ]
right you can't Define them more as a
party than this [ __ ] right here
it's I mean saying you know honestly at
this point just saying the quiet part
out loud they don't even care anymore
right they've admitted they've admitted
clearly you know you've got uh Charlie
Kirk saying democracy is bad don't trust
it you've got signs out there that say
it's overrated you've got any and all
opportunities that the Republicans have
to say hey look we're telling you
authoritarianism is the way we want to
go you've got election deniers which
let's just call them what they are
they're election liars and they so doubt
into our country's democracy where
voters will then look at this and say
well what's the point of voting if
they're already going to determine what
the outcome is you've got Mark finchamin
who wants to be the candidate for is the
candidate for Secretary of State you've
got uh the gubernatorial candidate Kerry
Lake these are people who are sowing
doubt in our democracy and that is their
plan I mean they've you know years ago
obviously started with voter suppression
they've got voter intimidation what's
happened like Arizona is what I would
consider the blueprint for any future
election strategy for the GOP it's
denied deny deny it's suppressed to vote
as much as possible like they are doing
in Pennsylvania and it's also intimidate
voters in Arizona and or in uh yeah in
Arizona
um and other states who actually want to
just drop off a ballot or whatever might
be these are all things that they're
putting in a place to say all right
great we've established what's legal and
what's not legal let's push the envelope
to see what more crazy [ __ ] we can get
away with to suppress the vote I mean
even Obama said on the campaign Trail
over the weekend last week he said look
there is nowhere in the world that a
party will be so actively against its
own voters they will actively suppress
their own voters it is insane to think
about that that we are one of the only
places in the world where there are
actively working against your own
interest and to suppress your vote and
if that's not enough of like oh [ __ ] we
should change things then like
I don't know what other other sign you
need besides that actual lawn sign that
literally says democracy is overrated
right
so Texas
turning points USA go ahead yeah yeah
keep that up I you know everybody
that ever hears our voice needs to
understand this comes out of Turning
Point USA this and what turn in Turning
Point USA is going directly after your
kids that's what they do they they are a
Youth Organization they're on every High
School junior college and college in the
country
your kids are exposed to this [ __ ]
they're exposed to this [ __ ] every damn
day at their school and you as a parent
need to be taking pictures like this up
to your school and go to the school
board meetings and say are you teaching
my kids that democracy is bad do you
have a turning point USA chapter
school because that's who's telling
everybody your kids
everybody
that democracy is bad
you know if you love your kids for
Christ's sake go down to the school and
make sure that the Turning Point USA
chapter is taken off their off your
campus Charlie Kirk has said enough
horrific [ __ ] that he doesn't need
access to your kids
oh he's an insurrectionist too I mean
yeah he's one of the ones that funded
the actual trying to overthrow our
democracy it's not surprising that not
only that but he's also someone that
can't tell the difference between a
dolphin fetus and a human fetus right
these are the people Priceless these are
the people that want to determine your
rights and what you have access to this
is the party the party that says
democracy is overrated the party that
says that they are a bunch of Patriots
but they want to overthrow the
government when they don't get the
results that they want and we're going
to see more of that [ __ ] after this
midterm it's look 2020 was not like a
flash in the pan one-time event it's
gonna happen in 2022 it's going to
happen in 2024 and we are going to
continue to see more and more of these
election Liars come out from under the
ground like they're [ __ ] cicadas
after a 17-year like hibernation they're
gonna pop up breed and then bury
themselves again and then pop up again
when the next terms of or the next
election happens and that's what they're
doing they're trying to breed this fear
and project their own wants and desires
onto other people and say that's
actually the Democrats that are doing
this when really when you look at it
they're taking away women's rights
they're taking away the actual uh rights
of people to actually vote I mean
I think this year it was 42 legislators
passed uh had proposed I wrote this down
uh because I wanted to bring it up 42
legislators have considered or at least
130 bills collectively across the U.S
just in 2022 alone 28 of them have been
passed and they've all been dealing with
law enforcement involved in the voting
process and in many cases vigilantism uh
is has been legalized and encouraged by
state governments and that doesn't
include all the other like you know
voter photo ID [ __ ] that they're
requiring which is just inherently
suppressing votes from the indigenous
population black community the Latino
Community these are all things that
they're trying to do because again
democracy is overrated and they can't
have people have an equal vote right
they can't allow people to have an equal
vote because if they do that then they
would find that they aren't actually the
ones in power anymore and they can't
actually rule over you so if you haven't
voted go vote but just keep in mind what
one party's trying to do against you and
what one party's trying to do for you
you know Trevor Noah hit this on the
head I'm sure you all have both seen
that that bit he did he was talking
about kind of how backwards we are here
in America if you made a commercial
about a roll of toilet paper and lied
about how many sheets were on that roll
the government would be on your ass for
false advertising
period but in a political ad
which can affect your ver can affect
your very democracy
you lie your ass off all day long you
can say any damn thing you want you know
and the government won't do [ __ ] to you
it's like Fair Play We are so backwards
about this [ __ ] we are so 100 backwards
about this [ __ ] and we need to I I'm a
firm believer that we [ __ ] up with our
first amendment we did I mean free
speech is great
but there has to be a limit on where
that free speech is I mean we've already
got a limit you can't yell fire in a
movie theater you can't we need to
revisit that limit
to where free speech is we really do
because if you've got people like the
murdochs
that are flagrantly openly and blatantly
lying every day to damage our democracy
you know we're under attack from a
[ __ ] foreign power there man
I mean these these are not Americans I
mean Fox is primarily owned by a [ __ ]
Aussie family and a Saudi family
for [ __ ] sake man what why are we
letting them do this I mean I love Free
Speech don't get me wrong I mean I don't
care if you say something
that pisses me off but when it comes to
actual 100 hey this is an ad this is
news this is you know there have has to
be some freaking guard rails there man
there has to be we're seeing how bad we
can get [ __ ] up in this country by
allowing this to happen well here's
here's uh let's check in with the Trump
copy machine
um fake Gabe here he says it's okay for
Twitter to censor conservatives but once
Twitter actually fact checks Democrats
cry salty tears I'm not sure exactly
what you're saying here I mean because
most the time you don't make any [ __ ]
sense at all because that's all you do
is regurgitate stupid [ __ ] I mean here's
another one I wonder why he's talking
about the election Democrats are going
to throw a tantrum you [ __ ] are
already throwing a crybaby tantrum
you're [ __ ] orange Mussolini Jesus
went on stage last night to stump for JD
Vance and he only talked about his
[ __ ] problems and the lead only
talking about his problems and the legal
problems he has [ __ ] hands think
about this fake Gabe you're [ __ ] dumb
leader went to make sure that you have a
United States senator who takes the who
takes the Ohio election to make sure you
have a majority in the Senate so you can
pass whatever laws and policy you want
to pass and the [ __ ] stood there
on stage bitching about the the [ __ ]
documents that he stole and how they're
holding him accountable not once he he
kept her in that right JD in that right
JD they [ __ ] me they [ __ ] me I'm I'm
the victim ain't that right JD I'm the
victim you should you should love me and
the other thing about it fake Gabe is
almost every [ __ ] one of those people
at the [ __ ] rally have been to dozens
of rallies it's the same [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] just like
you are the same [ __ ] in here
every single day every single day saying
the same stupid [ __ ] I know exactly what
you're gonna type I know exactly what
you're gonna say before you even [ __ ]
say it because it's the it's the dumb
[ __ ] that you that you have
institutionalized your [ __ ] entire
personality around that you absolutely
cannot think for your [ __ ] self that
you have no [ __ ] clue what you're
talking about so you just [ __ ]
straight up carbon copy whatever the
[ __ ] is fed to you on your Q Anon
Ivermectin horse page Facebook group you
dumb [ __ ] so I am glad that
you're here and you're listening I
really am I wish more of you stupid
[ __ ] would come here and listen to this
[ __ ] because you absolutely have no
other you have no other [ __ ] form of
[ __ ] information that is fed to you
then then just absolute vile [ __ ]
garbage vile garbage so I'm glad you're
here today and and another one I want to
point out here's here's another one that
fake Gabe said he's talking about when I
said the trickle-down economics with the
um with the oil companies maybe you
weren't [ __ ] listening maybe you need
to clean your [ __ ] ears you're saying
here here's the comment fake Gabe's
saying he said name one Economist that
actually believes in trickle-down
economics
okay
Democrats just spewing [ __ ] uh just
to see what sticks now I was talking
about the the trickle-down economics of
the oil companies doing very well
because they gouged your dumb ass and
you believe that it was Joe Biden
gouging you and and the reason why the
oil companies keep sticking it in you
without using any Vaseline is because
you're blaming it on the wrong person
and all the money that you're [ __ ]
getting gouging is trickling into their
[ __ ] pockets that's why the oil
corporations the old companies are doing
so [ __ ] well is because they're
[ __ ] you and because you're not
[ __ ] paying attention to the real
problem and you're blaming Joe Biden for
some dumb ass reason that's the
trickle-down economics that they want
they want your [ __ ] money to trickle
in their pockets without you holding
them accountable fake Gabe you dumb
[ __ ] thanks for being here by
the way thanks for being but also even
if you were to look at that just from
the actual results of what they reported
from their profits if you can tell me if
you can explain just the basic economics
of you know the the actual cost of goods
right the the cost of production in this
you would assume that if inflation and
all these other variables that you want
to claim in the economy were actually
pressuring the the price to actually go
up because you're limiting Supply or
whatever you want to realistically argue
here fake Gabe then explain how there's
a 500 plus percent profit in the last in
in the last yeah what was it last I'll
be able to do it you're probably he's
given Facebook links now right I mean so
like if you look I feel like Marathon
petroleum profits Rose to 4.48 billion a
545 increase over last year 694 million
this is just one example there's a ton
of other BP Phillips uh Chevron all of
these places if you look at it you'd
have to understand that you can you have
to understand where they're artificially
inflating the price
and and again and again there's nothing
wrong with corporations making profit in
the capitalist Society well you probably
right you can't blame someone else and
then [ __ ] about the profits that
they're making you stupid [ __ ]
inflation inflation is a normal economic
Factor what's the opposition what's the
opposite of inflation
deflation recession recession is that
yeah but here's the thing price gouging
right is not inflation
price gouging is an unnatural effect on
the economy
it is not
a natural
factor in our economy like inflation
everyone expected inflation after covet
what no one expected was for [ __ ]
Exxon Mobil to post their highest record
profit quarter in their entire existence
at the same time they're paying
politicians to tell you it's inflation
it's not [ __ ] inflation it's price
gouging that's what it is period even
and even if it was actually inflation
and and we said hey you know we you know
we should we can we can fix this but if
we identify the actual problem and say
it is price gouging look these these oil
companies are artificially inflating the
price at the pump because they see that
you guys are are in desperate need of
this gasoline so why not we kind of
bring up the price a little bit now when
given the chance when given the actual
opportunity to vote for something that
would protect you a consumer at the pump
from a company like Chevron or BP or any
of these other ones from artificially
inflating the price and say oh guys what
can we do it's inflation when you're
actually price gouging and we introduce
a bill on the floor and we say okay
great here's the solution here's so
here's one of the things that we can do
right now to help you the Democrats
Bring It Forward and the Republicans say
now we're good we don't want to do it
prove it you can literally you can
literally watch the vote on C-Span go
back eight Gabe says prove it now I'm
not sure exactly which which thing that
we said that he wants us to prove if
they gave listen you're so good at doing
your own research you're really good at
it I mean you go on your Facebook q and
on horse Pace Ivermectin group and I'm
sure you do a ton of research I'm sure
you know how to do this here's the thing
buddy here's the thing that you you
don't quite [ __ ] understand what
Texas Paul and what Gabe is trying to
tell you is that yes there is inflation
there is inflation it happens not only
is there inflation you can't have
gasoline in a dollar 25. it is not a
thing that exists you stupid [ __ ] and
the reason why you can't have gasoline
at a dollar 25 is because if you starve
and absolutely bury the oil companies
and the gas industry into the ground you
won't have gasoline you dumb
[ __ ] you just don't quite unders
understand how capitalism works that's
your [ __ ] problem here and you don't
understand that in a capitalist in a
capitalist Market we get to hold it we
the people who have the [ __ ] money
get to hold the people who are
accountable for that [ __ ] Market
accountable if you keep blaming the
wrong [ __ ] with your [ __ ]
dollars and your [ __ ] voice the gas
companies don't give a [ __ ] if if they
gouge you if if they're not going to be
held accountable what the [ __ ] do they
care if you're blaming biting it the
majority of the country is blaming the
wrong person and they're sitting there
going boy we love racking up these
prices we love really gouging fake Gabe
that dumb [ __ ] he goes and fills
up his stupid [ __ ] Trump truck every
goddamn Day 400 he doesn't even know
that we're [ __ ] him he thinks it's
Joe Biden this is fantastic we're gonna
keep going do you see how that works it
really is stupid [ __ ] but you know I
don't blame fake Gabe I mean he doesn't
know anything else works or why else why
would he know how capitalism works you
know I want to just expand on that just
one little bit yeah there's a creator
that I absolutely love and you've
probably seen her too I think Mr Global
too yes Mr Global too yeah the one thing
he says that's wrong okay because he
talks about my area of expertise which
is politics I listened to him for his
area of expertise but he crosses over
into the line of politics and he
basically says the same message over and
over again oil companies don't give a
[ __ ] about your politics they don't give
a [ __ ] about your feelings all they care
about is making money period
wrong [ __ ] wrong and I those old
[ __ ] that run these oil companies
are just as [ __ ] biased as everybody
else as everybody [ __ ] else and they
will vote against their own self-fucking
interest every time because if they
really did what Mr Global too
suggests that they only care about
making money they would never give a
[ __ ] Republican a dollar
ever because every time those [ __ ]
suckers are in power oil companies take
a [ __ ] dirt nap every [ __ ] time
every time it's a proven fact it is a
proven [ __ ] fact that when Democrats
are in office oil companies do well
because the economy does well
period
if they were really just interested in
making money oil companies would never
give a dollar to anybody but Democrats
here's here's another true copy machine
Dave Paddock here on Facebook he's
probably a Russian fake account too he
says Democrats logo I'm not sure what
that means oh he's he's I think what
he's trying to show here is Democrats
logo and then he's saying that the
tagline for Democrats is it's always
someone else's oh I see it's always
someone else about so so who who are you
blaming for the gas prices Dave Paddock
are you blaming yourself are you blaming
yourself for the gas prices because I
would almost bet that you're blaming
someone else you people really are
[ __ ] dumb why do you come why do you
do this why do you come to this show and
say stupid [ __ ] in the chat when you
know I'll pull it up and I will [ __ ]
eat your ass and kick your teeth in on
your [ __ ] point you literally you
[ __ ] for since January
21st of 2021 have been blaming someone
else Joe Biden for gas prices and milk
prices
for [ __ ] almost two years now you
people have been blindly blaming Joe
Biden since the moment he he [ __ ]
sworn in because he won and Trump lost
[ __ ] idiots you've been blaming him
for everything all your problems are Joe
Biden's fault when really honestly it's
because you vote for dumb [ __ ]
who don't have your interest at heart
just like just like Texas Paul said
right I don't know why it's not it's
also not Democrats logo I think what you
meant to say Dave uh Paddock uh is it's
Democrats slogan now logo is is like an
image is a visual it's an art piece a
slogan is like a it's a tagline a phrase
it's something you would say that's why
I was completely different things uh
guys this is why we need to fund public
education in okay these things are very
very important right whether it's
understanding uh how our bodies work and
understanding that your body is as a man
is different than a woman's and you
shouldn't you shouldn't have a say over
that you let them do what they want
and also just overall general education
proper grammar how we speak to each
other you know we know that we can't
just uh threaten people's lives and
assume that nothing's bad is going to
happen right like you have to understand
that
there is one party now again please go
vote how you vote it's up to you uh we
can't force you to do anything but we
will advocate for one group that is
actually working for your own interests
right working to protect you and you
have you have people like Dave Paddock
or fake Gabe or other people Jeremy
Johnson or who all these other you know
trolls that come in who clearly like
Trump or trumpism or whatever the
current Republican party is
they love to say oh well it's Biden's
fault
they love to as soon as he got into
office in 2021 they love to blame all of
the deaths on Biden right they love to
they love to blame all the gas prices
grocery prices this and that like like
it's Biden behind behind the uh the the
cloak and he's got a bunch of levers
that he's doing also you know I thought
he was asleep I thought he was tired and
in a basement right these things don't
make sense pick a lane and stay there I
think Texas Paul do you have something
yeah yeah uh you dumb [ __ ] boy
okay well let me let me see him make a
fake game fake game is having a comment
here that Gabe says Biden even said
quote no more drilling get owned so go
go ahead yeah uh no Biden didn't say no
more drilling get on in fact Biden said
drill your asses off I'll protect your
Market I will force the Saudis to cut
back on their production to make sure
you don't get [ __ ] again like you did
under truck you under Trump you ignorant
mother
what he's trying to what he's trying to
comment on is where uh Republicans whip
their dicks out and pissed in his ear
that you know and told him it was
[ __ ] raining and and and
all Biden did was to encourage drilling
he took permits that were issued to
[ __ ] oil companies that weren't using
them now if they're not [ __ ] using
them dumb [ __ ] Gabe if they're not
[ __ ] using them they're not [ __ ]
helping you
it's [ __ ] undeveloped underdone
[ __ ] production
are you turning right I mean they're not
dead [ __ ] helping you
cat turned on my my my rainbow filter
hold on let me fix it
it's perfect
it doesn't make any sense why why would
why would Biden say hey look I'm going
to uh I'm going to issue these permits
more people more permits you guys can
drill whatever you want
why would he issue more permits if he
said hey guys look no more drilling
that's my platform that's what I stand
on we're not going to drill we're not
going to have you know uh we're not
going to take in foreign oil it doesn't
really make any sense do you want to see
something I got a great video to show
you guys and it has nothing to do with
this this oil and the lies about gas
prices but it has to do with Republican
lies and Republican [ __ ] and getting
owned in real time like Gabe does here
every [ __ ] day but this is one of the
most beautiful videos I've ever seen
this is Matt Walsh that [ __ ] sick
weirdo who is absolutely obsessed with
children's genitalia he cannot stop
talking about children's genitalia this
[ __ ] Chris [ __ ] red flag right
there in it and let me tell you
something anyone anyone who is obsessed
with children like their genitalia are
posting pictures of people's Children
online [ __ ] you are [ __ ] weirdos you
are perverts and you are pedophiles that
is [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] but this is on
on Joe Rogan's podcast right and we all
know Joe Rogan is such a [ __ ] simp
any time he has someone on his podcast
and they say something to him he's like
oh yeah that sounds brilliant
is very much a chameleon right uh
podcaster because if he will morph to
whatever there and be like oh yeah
totally right because Matt Walsh would
be on the show and he'll believe
anything Matt Walsh says the opposite of
mad at Walsh will be on the show The Net
very next day and he'll believe whatever
the [ __ ] he says but this is beautiful
watch this [ __ ] as Joe Rogan's producer
[ __ ] fact checks Matt Walsh and Joe
Rogan in real time watch this is the
this is great footage watch this year
how many people have had this done
depends on what I don't think we have
exact numbers but it's if we're talking
about the drugs it's I mean Millions
um okay so what he's talking about is
gender reassignment surgery and and and
gender affirming drugs okay now he's
specifically talking about underage
people because he's absolutely obsessed
yeah with children
with children girls which the majority
of of the care that is given to gender
reassignment our gender confirmation in
this country if you look at the data the
majority of it underage is mostly
therapy and most of it is actual visual
changes clothing hair [ __ ] like that not
actual drugs not actually any kind of
surgery it's not a thing it's not a
[ __ ] thing they're [ __ ] Liars but
watch this in real time this is
beautiful
do you talk about hormone blockers yeah
millions of kids have been on hormone
blockers really uh
I'm sure someone's going to fact check
me on me but my my guess is that we're
in we're into the millions now at this
point yeah that would be my guess
um so here he says Tech spot to take a
quick break here he says here he says
there's Millions Right the dude is
staking his [ __ ] reputation
everything that he says his entire show
his entire stupid [ __ ] movie and book
that he's been promoting that they spent
gazillions of dollars on making run
around the country asking people what a
woman is because he doesn't know because
he's trying yeah he is still trying to
figure out because you know what the
reason he doesn't know what a woman is
he because because he really knows what
a girl is he doesn't know what a woman
is right you know he knows what a girl
is because he really is interested in
that 15 year old 16 year old girl as
he's talked about because that's the
peak that's when they're most the most
fertile that's one of the best have
babies that's when they're the most the
most or the best to take advantage of
sexually the guy's a [ __ ]
this is beautiful because he is on one
of the biggest platforms
in the country when Joe Rogan has a
microphone a lot of people are listening
right right this is so beautiful that he
was willing to so simply stake his
entire [ __ ] his entire [ __ ]
narrative to a number of 1 million so
simply it is [ __ ] insane to me that
he he claims to know everything about
everything that is transgender
transgender reassignment he claims to be
the expert on it because he knows and
he's a he's a [ __ ] bigot and he keeps
going after these people
and it is crazy to me that he is willing
to stick his entire reputation
on this one number now watch what
happens to him here watch what the back
and forth and then it gets to you and
watch this uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most I've
read a report recently that
um there were over a thousand done
between 2016 and 2019.
okay so think about that for a second
this is double mastectomies and he's
talking about reassignment surgeries
double mastectomies there was a thousand
between that that year now listen and
when you compare that to how many were
done between you know 2008 and 2015 it's
just it's a massive increase and uh
doesn't say what the increase is doesn't
give the number it's all [ __ ] keep
listening over a thousand girls gender
affirming double mastectomies in that in
that and he says girls he says girls
because again he's obsessed with
children but that is just absolutely
blatant right so he's so just to clarify
because I haven't heard once yet the
actual age range that he's talking about
he says girls right or where the study's
from then but what I'm curious is like
is this not like you know if there's a
woman who has breast cancer right like
is is he excluding that or is he just
throwing that in there and saying girls
that's what I want to know right well he
likes the word girl let's let's see what
let's see what how he gets [ __ ] can he
just gets owned by the [ __ ] internet
and facts watch this it's hilarious that
time frame girls you're talking about
prepubes right minors uh and that's just
up until 2019 and then we know that uh
there's been this exponential increase
with all this stuff year over year so
um it's it's a lot it's too many you
know one having this happen to one kid
is way too many it's a lot more than one
yeah look if you're an adult and you
want to do that and you understand who
you are and what you are and this is how
you feel you should progress you're an
adult this is a free country you should
be able to do whatever you want but when
you're talking about doing that to
Children the fact that so many people
are on board and so many people are
angry if you have like people are going
to be angry at us that we're having
these conversations
yeah they will so here's the thing is
that Joe Rogan is saying is saying the
[ __ ] out loud that a lot of people think
and that's the reason why Matt Walsh has
spun this narrative the way that he spun
it that's why they've stoked the fear
that's why the Boston hospital and the
Children's Hospital in Boston have
gotten bomb threats and everything else
because of this [ __ ] because Joe
Rogan says well people are going to be
mad that we're saying what we're saying
what you're saying is [ __ ] lies wrong
it's [ __ ] lies and and you know it's
[ __ ] lies but watch this when when
they get shown this it is beautiful a
little bit and I also
I I actually think that uh that that
this shouldn't this shouldn't be
happening to
now you see here on this screen are they
seeing the light right now what is
hilarious is now um I forget Joe Rogan's
producer's name offhand
um but he sits there and he does this
where he'll pull up facts or Joe will
ask him to look up something like I like
I do Gabe yeah and and that's generally
a producer that it's what they do and he
pulls up because that's why the screen
gets bright and they kind of look over
it's because he's pulling up the
information in real time for them this
is listen to what Matt Walsh says at the
end here
it's a it's a very small number if
that's right it says over the last five
years there were at least 4 780
adolescents who started puberty blockers
and at a prior gender dysphoria
diagnosis
not even close not even not even in the
civilians Tony he said millions
it's insane and that's over the last
that's in five years you're talking less
way less than a thousand a thousand a
year yeah watch this and you know what
he but he said it was exponential what's
going on here right
the fact that it is such a small number
is why they didn't do it because there's
no [ __ ] there's no [ __ ]
repercussion for going after a group
that small unless we do it we the
general population say [ __ ] you dick but
so let me throw one thing out there okay
this isn't the [ __ ] 60s this isn't
the 70s it's not even the [ __ ] 80s
when we didn't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] when
it came to trans people we didn't want
to talk about it we didn't want to know
about it now we know a transsexual
person has a different brain
then they're they're they're
genitalia that they're born with we can
identify it it's actually something we
can scan their brain with an MRI and
[ __ ] know if they're trans not one
you know everybody's so worried that
we're gonna have gender or gender
affirming gender affirming treatment to
someone who's not transsexual and we're
gonna force them on it no [ __ ] we know
we can see via an MRI if someone
presents with symptoms where they say
hey I actually don't feel right this
doesn't feel right to me I am supposed
to be a girl or I am supposed to be a
boy I know it I can feel it you know and
they they talk to psychologists
beforehand that actually know how to
talk to people to determine whether or
not they are transsexual or whether or
not they're just having an issue of
gender identity you know that that's up
here we know this now it's not a matter
of guessing
and they know that if they take someone
who is 10 or 12 years old who absolutely
knows because at 10 or 12 years old you
know if you like girls or not
you knew that [ __ ]
we know you know whether somebody can
identify we I mean I knew at 10 or 12
years old if I was a boy or a girl I did
I knew that nobody had to tell me I
didn't have to go to a doctor
if we give them treatment the hormone
treatment they're talking about
the pain the suffering
the difficulty
the fact that they don't have the
suicide rates that they know would
normally do I mean we can actually give
these people Health Care to help them
and this [ __ ] because he wants to make a
point and suck his [ __ ] right-wing
dick for some more money is out here
lying about people and and forcing them
into [ __ ] situations where they will
have 60 percent higher suicide rates
because he doesn't know [ __ ] all about
what he's talking about but he's
presenting himself as a [ __ ] expert
when really is is a [ __ ] pedophile
that's focused on goddamn kids all the
time well here's what I'll tell you too
in in that point is that this fact here
has nothing to do with gender me genital
mutilation because that's the thing they
keep talking about that's the the
surgery this has to do with the drugs
listen listen to how they own themselves
here it says it's kind of under counted
but that's
yeah
I mean I I would guess you know hundreds
of thousands at this but I could be oh
now he wants hundreds of millions sounds
great yeah 91 centers are down million
sounds great well let me back it up
listen listen to the very last part of
what he says could be wrong
million sounds great
yeah
um the Media Matters will have a fun
with that clip yeah Media Matters will
have fun with that clip because he knows
he's [ __ ] just making [ __ ] up right
he's making [ __ ] up he has been like you
said Paul he's making [ __ ] up because
he's a pervert and he's got some [ __ ]
weird thing about this thing and he
keeps his did you know on his Twitter
page he self-identifies as a [ __ ]
fascist
self-identifies go to Twitter go look it
up I'm telling you go look it up fake
Gabe go look at it it's just fascist
right there right there on his [ __ ]
Twitter page Matt Walsh and he
absolutely cannot stop thinking about
children's genitalia and he was
literally saying just moments before
they pulled up a simple [ __ ] study
online that showed that no it's less
than a thousand thousand people who
actually receive the actual drug
treatment the drug treatment who most of
them start when they're they're later in
their adolescence like 16 17 and 18.
right and and most of the time if you go
actually just look the [ __ ] up you would
know that a 10 12 13 14 year old that is
having a a gender identity crisis or or
they they have that problem
where they are trans they usually use
clothing hair the actual physical look
of of what they can change without doing
drug or surgery the main part is just
the actual therapy of it that's what it
is and Matt Walsh is a sick [ __ ] to to
[ __ ] not only demonize these people
but then go out and say there's millions
of them like there's an army like
there's an army of transgender people
that are gonna [ __ ] make you trans or
some [ __ ] which is absolutely [ __ ]
even more Bonkers to think that just
because there are trans people that
they're forcing people to be trans
people
yeah [ __ ] and it's it's also the fact
you know that you touched on a moment
ago is is they they
don't have an ability well here
Republicans lack empathy and empathy is
a key way for understanding someone
else's condition to understand hey
you're not so good right now in terms of
whatever socioeconomic status whatever
it might be I wanna I empathize I wanna
help you as much as I can Republicans
are like ah [ __ ] you I don't really care
that's what they believe that's that's
the approach they have so let's be clear
about that so when it comes to something
like this
they don't understand it because they
they they want to believe off I if it's
out of sight out of mind I don't want to
I want to deal with it if I just
completely cancel it out if I you know
put in place this fascist kind of uh you
get this you don't get this I don't care
about your rights kind of thing
Republicans also run under this well if
I'm near you I catch it like it's this
[ __ ] very bizarre
misunderstanding and also
um inability to to Really to empathize
with this person's condition whatever it
might be and in this clip you've got
Matt Walsh which by the way this is one
moment where he's like oh [ __ ] I was
proved wrong but I I it should be like
Daddy yeah but the thing is like in
every other you know day of the week
when he's on his show he's going to push
the idea that there are millions people
are mutilating themselves children are
doing this parents are forcing it all
this [ __ ] teachers are are teaching
critical race Theory they're forcing
this and making them feel guilty
whatever it might be there's just a
bunch of fear-mongering because in in
the beginning that clip he goes
someone's probably going to fact check
me but it's like because he knows he
knows what he's saying is a lie and so
in that moment he's like well if I can
kind of finesse this answer to kind of
just cover my situation he says
someone's gonna fact check me but there
are millions and over this time it has
grown year over year exponentially where
he just doubles down no numbers no
figures no stats nothing and then when
he does oh my God and then when he does
get proven wrong he's like oh well I
guess it uh you know it it it's like the
hundreds of thousands so it went from
Millions to hundreds of thousands to
being way way way way way less than that
4 000 or whatever was total over that
time period well here's fake Gabe with
another lie the same stupid [ __ ] you
fools think CRT is not in schools it is
in schools but it's in it's in law
universities you [ __ ] idiots five law
schools and and you have to be an
advanced student to get into that
elective so
you'll never ever be allowed in a CRT
course you or your Offspring or anybody
you [ __ ] know would never be allowed
because you have to be tops in one of
five law schools to actually get a
course in CRT game you are in no way in
any danger of you or anyone that came
out of your [ __ ] bodily fluids ever
[ __ ] getting near CRT I want to have
a little pushback because I believe that
we can create a better country if we
just vote for people who have some
common [ __ ] sense that fate Gabe's
children grandchildren
great-grandchildren will actually get a
decent education in this country
eventually and they will learn what
facts and what uh fiction is and I gotta
say I I gotta I gotta move to this
because we're we're getting close we're
over the bot are the the bottom of the
second hour here they're talking about
fact and fiction okay
um this is a taco
a lot of people have
um doubted that this is now now Gabe you
have told me before it really is not
about what is in the Shell it is about
the shell and itself so this is not no
no Tony this is how is this not
a taco I'm gonna go to bat for this eh
I'm gonna spread my taco propaganda here
it is Taco Tuesday this is disgusting
you got a bunch of Slim Jims and [ __ ]
cheese whiz that you who doesn't like
slime gems who doesn't like cheese whiz
uh like I wouldn't this is
a taco I you know what I would consider
this this is like a this is like a a gas
station wrap you know it's not a taco
yeah I was gonna say the ratios are
wrong you know the ratio is like three
Slim Jims and some cheese rolled up Taco
Bell Maybe I think this is pretty close
to Taco Bell right are you telling me
right now that you would you would
honestly if given if given the
opportunity I will [ __ ] make this
thing and eat it on a live stream [ __ ]
oh my God 100
I will make this [ __ ]
and I will eat this on a live stream oh
God
this boy to a real restaurant get him
some carne asada and and something
decent so he knows that this is [ __ ]
repulsive I like Slim Jims I like cheese
whiz and I like tortillas so what the
look if you want it here's the other way
you could approach this if you took all
of those things separate maybe you could
have like a a gas station uh charcuterie
board right oh so you mean like you mean
like you tear up like a piece of the
yeah like sure if you and then put a
piece of it
if you had all of these separate you
tear off your little tortilla assuming
that right a tortilla or some sort of
wrap you've got your little you know
cheese right there you got your meat
stick you just take boom it's like it's
a meat yeah my meat it's sick it's a
cheap charcuterie board is what it is a
gas station
yeah I'm using that I'm totally stealing
that gas station charcuterie listen I I
really I'm open to all ideas here on how
to eat this thing this is but I just
don't understand I just don't understand
this is not why no no but there are
certain there are certain criteria or at
least bare minimum this is just meat
cheese and a tortilla thrown together
this is what the [ __ ] [ __ ] is a taco I
mean you can make meat cheese and a
tortilla a taco right who made this
you're literally causing me pain right
now I told my doctor to watch this show
do you know how many [ __ ] needles are
gonna be stuck in me how many blood
tests over this [ __ ] taco man that's
hilarious well I mean I again I like
Slim Jims I'd eat a [ __ ] slim jim for
a snack all the time I like cheese whiz
you know the best the best thing about
Jesus is you get a Ritz cracker The
Buttery ones and you and you really you
hammer down hard on the on the cheese
whiz and it's like this big this big
gulp of on a on a cracker and you eat
that something this is this is oh you
know what actually is a good way to say
that taco is fake Gabe's brain on Maga
it honestly are you trying to get me to
be against this thing because I'm just
saying look there this is just not
something that should go together in
this in this medium okay
grease on the and then the [ __ ] look
how beautiful that what some would cause
cheese there how it's got the ripples in
it and it's nice and slathered on there
I I can tell you this look I'm gonna
give you this okay if you had like three
if you had three Slim Jims on there and
half the whiz and it was rolled up and
and hot because that cheese is [ __ ]
cold right there that's gross
in a microwave yeah and throw it in the
microwave do a roll up with three times
next to you brother I I tell you what
let's get some slim jim some tortillas
and and somewhere is a next show we will
nuke that up and we will try it
I'm I I'll I'll I'll live stream this
[ __ ] that's great I'm gonna I'm gonna
sit here and I'm just gonna watch
the most I'll do the most I'll have is
this all the way I haven't had a slim
jim because I don't know where you find
those outside of like an oasis on a road
trip but I haven't had a slim jim since
I was come on a kid we're all over Texas
is [ __ ] disgusting what [ __ ] no no no
no no there there are several different
types of cheese whiz see there's the
American if it comes out of a can if it
comes better there's the sharp cheddar
if you've got cheese coming out of a can
Tony nope nope what other place
beautiful place
take take a rich cracker put a jalapeno
on it a little bit of cheese whiz
the only way I have cheese is shredded
crumbled or a block that's it that's how
I do it I don't have it out of a can I
just don't I just don't do it it doesn't
it it does is Gabe Rich or something man
I mean this was like a staple in our
house right spoiler alert I was the one
I I didn't wanna I didn't want to reveal
this until the midterm election results
came out but I am here on this show to
reveal that I am rich because I am the
sole California Powerball winner oh yeah
highest winning on record so yeah is
that a thing did they someone actually
win the Powerball yeah it's uh I just
got a notification wait wait and there's
only one ticket one ticket how much was
it up to
2.04 billion dollars holy [ __ ]
somebody's a billionaire today
congratulations two point billion
dollars so what because because it was
in California so they're gonna have a
lot of tax I doubt they're going to get
a full billion dollars and if anyone if
anyone somehow was listening to this and
they were the winner or they know the
winner somehow get a tax attorney you
got to get an attorney a lawyer you need
to protect you create a company do not
go open up a safety deposit box and and
put that ticket in it right now don't
[ __ ] first of all don't get the money
yet until you talk to your attorney set
up a trust fund don't do it sign the
[ __ ] either don't sign the [ __ ] either
put it in a lock box only him that
you're the only one that has the key
don't [ __ ] because they're someone's
going to steal that money you know who
would really like to have that money
oh who Trump Elon Musk
oh my God have you seen this
and this guy is [ __ ] he is running
out of money fast he's he claims he's
losing four million dollars a day which
makes me believe he's actually probably
losing about eight or ten yeah um
because you know he's a [ __ ] lying
sack of [ __ ] well he's got it he's gotta
pay I think his first payment on the 13
billion dollar loan is due in April he
owes almost it's like a half a billion
dollars is the interest right right 1.5
1.5 or 1.8 isn't it Gabe that's the
interest or that's the payment that's
the no that's the big yeah that's the
that's the payment on it so that's what
he owes because again he's got 13
billion so you're gonna you know
interest accumulates very quickly on uh
on a 13 billion dollar loan debt and so
he's got and you know Elon is a great
genius he's a he's a businessman of the
century this guy this guy buys a company
overvalued 44 billion he's got uh
payments that are due his first one is
in April he cut half the people at the
company and said we got to cut money and
we got to save money by making these
budget cuts then over on Saturday there
were early reports of people that were
cut from Twitter that were now being
contacted to say hey why don't you guys
come back and work at Twitter again so
we're already seeing the effects of this
great capitalist businessman this genius
[ __ ] up and find out what's not only
that and not only that but with the
advertisers leaving they keep in mind
the advertisers have 100 percent
leverage right now they don't need
Twitter to advertise their company they
could do everything they could do
[ __ ] click ads banner ads they could
do everywhere else they do not do
Twitter
and so I don't even
yeah and so and so now Elon Musk has
only one well well rather the move that
he's decided to make as this great
genius businessman is to threaten a
thermonuclear exposure of the names and
companies of who have uh taken away
their who have paused their funding or
have said we're not going to work with
Twitter anymore because we don't know
what's going on which is also a safe
kind of approach to say we don't know
what the [ __ ] this platform is anymore
so why would we advertise our company
with it especially if we know that
you're going to be promoting you know
free hate speech is what you're doing so
now he's finally yeah and so he's not
only threatening these companies to
expose them
but he needs them so it's the it's a
very nonsensical approach to if you're
if you're desperate for money you
threaten the people that have leverage
on you that have the money
doesn't make a lot of sense guys
I told Elon Musk three million bucks
and one hundred thousand dollars a tweet
every time he [ __ ] tweets it's going
to cost you a hundred thousand bucks
more but for three million bucks plus a
hundred thousand dollars per tweet I
will help you put this [ __ ] back in the
horse because ninety percent of what he
has said is not the problem it's how we
[ __ ] said it right ninety percent of
it you know nobody disagrees with free
speech
it's how this [ __ ] opens his
mouth and the diarrhea falls out
yeah I mean I literally clearly this
right now he's clearly not a leader he's
clearly no not at all no
I mean there were people I know I know
people who work at Twitter and have
friends at Twitter uh who literally said
I am waiting they were they were
patiently and kind of uh excited in a
way on Friday to wait for their email to
come in with what their determination of
the role was to say you're either at the
company or you're not at the company
because they're like this place since he
took over and even leading up to it it
was kind of like on edge but ever since
he took over they were like this place
has been a [ __ ] [ __ ] show I'm working
14 hour plus days on a deadline that is
completely arbitrary and now we find out
that Elon Musk is like oh yeah well
we're not gonna actually launch this uh
verification tool until after the
midterms why the [ __ ] there's no reason
I've worked in product at building
actual products in Tech in San Francisco
for 11 plus years you never you never
release a product a major product for a
company the day before a huge traffic
event like the Mitch term elections
today his plan was to launch a
verification tool
on November 7th a day before you do not
do that that is something you there are
two rules you never release a product
the day before a major event and you
never release a product on a Friday when
everyone goes home for the weekend and
then [ __ ] goes crazy those are two big
rules you never do and the third rule is
you certainly don't fire 50 percent of
your staff that would actually be in
charge of handling that like content
moderation the AI ethics team the human
rights activists or the the human rights
legal Team all of these groups were just
some of them on top of engineering
design sales Communications these are
all groups that were fired across the
board 50 some teams just wiped out
entirely because Elon decided we don't
need them and now after he made these
decisions and has really cornered
himself he now is saying oh [ __ ] I
actually need to hire these people back
I don't have a comms team I don't have a
human rights team people online were
like why does Twitter need human rights
do you know the amount of [ __ ] that go
was online the amount of like people
have to get have people but this is why
but this is why the corporate
advertisers took their money and they
walked because they can't trust that
[ __ ] and that was he is
literally doing terms of service by
tweet and they can't there's no
consistency there's no one there to have
any kind of [ __ ] continuity it's just
him it's just his [ __ ] his weak ass
mind his weak snowflake mind setting
policy as it goes along with what he
wants in the moment it's crazy ass [ __ ]
it's crazy as [ __ ] here's some other
crazy [ __ ] speaking of a of a [ __ ]
fake billionaire who who's a snowflake
and a [ __ ] this guy's such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] they said he was gonna come out on
stage last night and announce that he's
gonna run and I said yesterday that
[ __ ] should do it but he
wouldn't I said he wouldn't because he's
a little [ __ ] he's a baby back little
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he's a and he [ __ ]
proved me right here's the [ __ ] clip
of him saying that he's gonna announce
later in two weeks and that the the two
weeks from now will be the later date
that he announces the announcement that
he wants to announce and then the
announcement that he's going to announce
is going to be huge and it possibly will
be pushed back probably another huge
weeks but let's listen
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
foreign
on theme song he is he is uh he really
[ __ ] plays for like 10 minutes and he
talks over it and he does his dramatic
kind of speech and right now he's you
know we'll see I wonder I do wonder if
the announcement on November 15th at
Mar-A-Lago was actually going to because
remember there was uh it was September
right September
or I'm trying to remember when he was
originally planning oh no sorry
he was planning to make another
announcement at Mar-A-Lago but then
canceled last minute but I forget why I
was in poor taste there was a date that
it oh it was was it no no it was January
6th oh he was planning his announcement
on January 6th at Mar-A-Lago and
canceled it last minute uh because
people were like ah that that that's not
so good and so now he's saying November
15 2022 one week from today he's going
to make an announcement Mar-A-Lago no do
you want to know what the announcement's
going to be that he's going to announce
another announcement listen he cannot
run and the reason why he can't run is
because he can't run against Joe Biden
if he announces now he's in a Republican
primary not a [ __ ] general election
that is what he that is what his
supporters do not understand
they do not understand that he's not
going to be running against a Democrat
as much as he'll talk about it if he
enters the race and someone else enters
the race he will have to run against
them he will have to run how are you
suspended you know why he's suspended
his announcement he was going to
announce yesterday but do you know why
he's suspended his announcement
because the GOP told him [ __ ] you're
not a candidate we don't owe you [ __ ]
right we're not paying your legal bills
and even if you announce we're not
paying your [ __ ] legal bills and he's
like well [ __ ] maybe I need to think
about this because I got all the money I
grifted I can keep that but if I
announce I can't keep it you know I've
got you know I've got and it this is
[ __ ] yeah yeah
the GOP is not funding his [ __ ] man he
thought he was so [ __ ] stupid he
thought if he announced that he was
gonna run that suddenly all those
[ __ ] free GOP lawyers were coming
back they're not yeah they're not the
GOP has told him [ __ ] you buddy Chuck
you buddy it ain't happening man it
ain't happening and if you need those
after DeSantis and the GOP said look
this guy is on the ballot
this election right if you open your
[ __ ] mouth about Ron DeSantis again
you're done he may have cost you you're
[ __ ] done he may have cost him that
race yeah which he may have [ __ ] him
right [ __ ] him yeah this is why this is
why I want him to run I want him to
[ __ ] run is because it'll bang him up
so [ __ ] bad he won't have any [ __ ]
money he won't he won't be able to Griff
the way he's grifting right now and
he'll have to run against around
DeSantis or a Chris Christie or whoever
the [ __ ] of the other nominees are
because he'll be in a primary not a
[ __ ] general election because Joe
Biden doesn't have to announce he
doesn't have to announce Joe Biden said
I know who that [ __ ] running
against I ain't I ain't running yet yeah
I'm being president I'm doing my job is
what he can do and I believe I believe
that the Democratic party should be
behind Trump announcing because the
other thing that is that is um that is
obvious that's gonna happen he's going
to be indicted on this document this
document scheme
um where he stole our [ __ ] documents
and he broke the espanyol's actually he
keeps talking about the presidential
records act you broke the Ashby and I
jack you dumb [ __ ] but here's
here's the thing is that he's going to
be banged up on charges for that and
that they think that's going to be good
for him to be charged for that they
think oh this is gonna be great he's
gonna be charged he's going to be in the
news like
democrats should be be calling for this
son of a [ __ ] to run with his
indictments with the court dates with
him being banged up where he can't
afford legal fees where he can't [ __ ]
Griff money they should be encouraging
this stupid [ __ ] to run they should be
encouraging it every [ __ ] moment
because he he's not gonna lay lay low
he's going to lay waste to any [ __ ]
Republican rather their [ __ ] hold
office or they want to hold office he's
gonna do it so I mean any anyone anyone
who speaks out against him is
immediately his enemy right these are
all people he'll immediately the tactic
that he goes to is he comes up with some
dumb nickname or some kind of way to
refer to them calls him out they need to
prove intention fake well he's talking
about the document Escape case hey fake
game I don't know if you've read I don't
know if you've read all the [ __ ] that
doj has dropped in court because you're
dumb [ __ ] Mussolini Jesus opened his
mouth but they have intent dummy and by
the way way they gave cash Patel the guy
who went on TV saying that Trump
Declassified all this stuff they gave
him immunity from crimes
immunity from crimes for his testimony
so yeah they have intent buddy they have
intent not only that but also and what
you're talking about and what you're
talking about with cash Patel I was
talking to somebody that actually has
been through these prosecutions before
and that's really [ __ ] rare in a
federal case experience
yeah and and I will tell you he gave
them very very sweet candy
for to get that deal nobody gets that
[ __ ] deal well I don't know what kind
of profits I don't know what kind of
profits he did in advance to negotiate
The Limited use immunity but limited use
immunity is very rare not only that cash
Patel at even giving limit to use
immunity is not out of the woods because
he's only limited to a few crimes that
he committed that he's going to have to
testify to and that is why it's limited
use and he is in big trouble and he
knows that his lawyers know it and
they're just they're just mitigating and
trying to hold off 20 20-year and dirty
30 sentences on cash Patel
um cash Patel told them exactly what
Donald Trump's tank tastes like I
guarantee you he told them everything
and you think my [ __ ] Slim Jim G
cheese whiz Taco is gross we're talking
about how Trump we're eating one next
week we're eating one next week I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it I will I
will I will sit here and bear witness
with all of the other people and watch
you do it the most I'll do is I'll have
a slim jim with a tortilla but I'm not
putting that [ __ ] up she's just put the
cheese whiz on the [ __ ] on top
because you know how many people you're
offending by pissing on Whiz man I'm
just saying I just don't if the cheese
is in a can it ain't for me I'll take
look I'll take I'll take the entire
pro-democracy
Eastern cheese
right now he's anti-chees I'll take a
block of cheese I'll buy some charp or
some sharp cheddar cheese from the
grocery store and I'll I'll cut it up
and it's gonna get some kind of [ __ ]
Gourmet beef stick that's 100 it's just
gonna be generic grocery stores cheddar
cheese no I'm talking about you're gonna
make a a fancy version of this
Slim Jims now too they have fancy ones
not like the old how would I know that I
don't eat Slim Jims you don't go into a
[ __ ] gas station and look at the slim
jim aisle I mean they got a whole aisle
of Slim Jims like it's a whole [ __ ]
Iowa you can come to Texas man there's
actually a slim jim select I will take a
picture and send it to you there is a
slim jim selection in my grocery store I
guarantee I I'm telling you man it must
be a southern thing I don't know it's a
thing well everybody uh go vote today's
the day it's Tuesday it's Texas Paul
Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday but it's
election Tuesday it's election day and
one of these days we'll have this as a
national holiday and we'll still be
yelling and screaming even on the news
maybe by the next election depending on
the outcome of this election
I'm still waiting on the goddamn
daylight savings time Bill to be passed
the time [ __ ] changed and I didn't
even know it did you I didn't even
[ __ ] I didn't realize it till like
like three o'clock that day I'm like
Jesus Christ I've been living in the
past okay everybody it's Tuesday it's
election day go out and vote if you
haven't voted already go do it now make
sure you have your plan in place if you
have any trouble any trouble whatsoever
voting remember there is a hotline it's
1-800 or it's 866 it's 866 our vote it's
eight six six our vote is a hotline if
you have any trouble uh start saying
provisional ballot Most states you can
do a provisional ballot if you have any
trouble at the poll
um if you've already voted if you
already have your vote cast make sure
you're encouraging your community
members your family your friends to go
vote if they need a ride give them a
ride whatever we can do to get as many
people at the polls today as possible to
be counted because trust me when they
say oh we're gonna make sure no one
steals it they're trying to so just vote
vote vote vote vote today is the day to
save democracy it is here we have
finally reached the day that your voice
will matter everyone come back ever
tomorrow same time same place I promise
we will be here as we are here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter or twitch tomorrow
Right Here YouTube Twitter twitch and
Facebook Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon